[Music]
hello a very good morning to you it's
seven o'clock here in the united kingdom
we are at cop 26 in glasgow again this
morning yep we are still here as indeed
are the delegates are they any closer to
a deal good morning good morning not
quite yet they are exhausted they
brought their sleeping bags a long day
negotiations ahead okay more from ashna
to come they're all trying to save this
it's saturday the 13th of november
going into overtime negotiations over a
possible final agreement at the cop 26
climate summit will continue today
[Music]
making their voices heard demonstrators
urge countries not to water down the
agreement over curbing fossil fuels and
providing climate funding
i'm in one of australia's coal mining
regions where people say banning coal
would be catastrophic
beijing's not quite in tune with the
moon music at cop26 far from cutting
emissions china's all for building more
coal-fired power stations
and here in chennai in india the flood
waters have receded but there are still
millions of people at risk from the
impacts of climate change
also making the news this morning a man
dies and a pensioner is critically ill
in hospital after they were stabbed in a
street in west london
[Applause]
and finally free a court in california
terminates britney spears
conservatorship the singer says it's the
best day ever
in sport england are just one point away
from world cup qualification after a
harry kane hat trick helps them thrash
albania
the weather mild and settled for most
but some light rain in places too
and at a quarter to eight we'll take a
look at the papers with journalists
thomas copeland and pa's political
correspondent jerry scott
[Music]
good morning from glasgow where we are
into extra time as negotiators try to
thrush out a climate deal we're
expecting some kind of updated draft
agreement in the next few hours the main
sticking points include subsidies for
coal and fossil fuels and financial help
for poorer countries our science and
technology editor tom clark reports
[Applause]
for many the time for quiet negotiation
has passed
after 12 days of patient u.n process
demonstrators staged a symbolic walkout
at the lack of ambition from leaders at
cop26
governments aren't listening to us and
we want to say that the outcomes here
are not going to be just
we want to see action where everywhere
all the demands are met and the fossil
fuels are kept in the ground
we've got to be going a lot further and
a lot faster at this point there's a
massive disconnect between what these
activists are calling for what's
actually being reflected in the text
being negotiated here in glasgow
the elements of it are actually quite
radical as far as the un process goes
question is will those elements survive
to the end
after pulling an all-nighter corralling
groups of divergent negotiators cop
president alok sharma now has to rush
nearly 200 ministers to agree positions
before time runs out we need to all get
back to work
let us drive progress and forge
consensus and as many of you have said
the eyes of the world are on us
key parts of the negotiating text about
cutting coal and finding more finance
for poor countries have been watered
down but their meaning survives
and so far no country wants to be seen
as an obstacle and many may even
compromise more we've actually proposed
many of the uh of the of the solutions
that have been put on the table that
have allowed the negotiations to move
forward
uh so uh i don't see how one could
believe that we would be
we could be an obstacle to anything
quite to the contrary but differences
potentially intractable ones remain the
summits aim to keep 1.5 alive hinges on
countries agreeing to return next year
with more ambition to cut carbon but
that's still a red line for some who
won't give up fossil fuels and for
others who want more time
i think that the arrangement should be
based on the framework and provisions of
the paris agreement to allow party space
and time in implementing their pledges
one thing that could bring china and
others round is more money for the
developing world where it has many
interests
the u.s has definitely thrown its
diplomatic weight at cop
but not its wallet
special envoy kerry what progress has
been made where are they before yes
i think we're making progress we're
doing what negotiators should do we're
negotiating
worried about finance we will get there
the talks will now extend well into
today testament to the difficulties that
remain but also that a deal is still on
the table
[Applause]
outside some protesters tried to climb
the miles of fencing surrounding cop26
many negotiators inside must know how
they feel
scaling the seemingly impossible but
with genuine hope it's not all in vain
tom clark sky news glasgow
national is also still here chance of a
deal today we hope so i mean the new
renewed target i suppose to aim for is 4
p.m today it's what lots of officials
are saying sort of off the record but
you're right we are expected to get this
third draft of this agreement in the
next few hours last night well yesterday
morning sorry it dropped at seven
o'clock in the morning it's hoped that
we'll get it around a similar time today
but it's all about the negotiators who
have been spending the night here kay
this centre is open 24 hours and they've
brought their sleeping bags with them it
has been extremely exhausting for them
they've been spending not only time
talking to each other but also uh
sleeping as well but it's all about
keeping that target of 1.5 alive and
we've got a little graphic to to outline
what's being discussed in the agreement
so to get to 1.5 degrees there is an
argument to achieve that countries will
need to phase out coal and there will be
a close focus on whether countries
commit to phase out other fossil fuel
subsidies but crucially it's all about
the finance isn't it we've spoken about
this a lot developing nations will also
be watching to see if a pledge to
provide that 100 billion dollars a year
to mitigate and adapt to the effects of
climate change will be met and we will
see if states are willing to offer
detailed plans to cut their carbon
emissions but it is all about um the
detail really it's it's reaching a point
where with things like
the cutting of emissions and the targets
but also the fossil fuel subsidies saudi
arabia is one country that's wanting
that part of the agreement to be removed
nations in the eu other nations as well
wanting that part of it to stay it
survived the second draft of the
agreement will it stay that's the big
question really all eyes on the fossil
fuels i was reading something last night
that said uh we might hear something
around about eight o'clock this morning
um on the breakfast show let's see for
now
thanks so much indeed thank you meantime
let's take you to chennai in india where
floods are starting to recede thankfully
but climate change is still a huge
concern katharina vittotsy is there for
us hello to you katarina good morning
you've been wading around in smelly
water all week what's it looking like
now
well a relief for our crew and certainly
a relief for the many millions of people
in chennai as these flood waters have
now receded after now about a day and a
half of this as you can see pretty hot
and dry weather but as you say climate
change still something which does
threaten many many millions of people
across this country we're standing now
on this beach next to the bay of bengal
it's a stretch of water it's the top of
the indian ocean and it borders india
bangladesh and myanmar and as
temperatures rise globally we've
witnessed how communities have been
affected by the changes that that planet
warming has on the water that's warming
in the shores which obviously a country
like india with a huge coastline is
desperately impacted and i think as we
look over the agreements and the talks
and the discussions and crucially the
decisions that come out of cop26 there
will be many people here who will know
that what decisions happen in glasgow
will impact their futures here it is
a strange situation in some respects
there are many people here who simply
don't know what climate change is you
ask a question about climate change and
people sort of shrug and say why should
we be concerned about a global climate
crisis when we are more concerned about
our short-term families survival it's as
stark as that for many of the millions
of people in india that live in poverty
but we've also been speaking with young
climate activists i spoke to one 22 year
old just this morning and i asked what
she thought of the draft agreement so
far she put it extremely bluntly she
said it wasn't enough it was too little
too late and she quoted greta tunberg
someone who is very much held in high
esteem by young climate activists here
who say we have to do seemingly
impossible we have to do it now
okay thank you katarina let's take you
to beijing now should we china not quite
on board with what's being discussed
here in glasgow although there has been
significant movement hasn't there tom
during the week
yeah i mean expectations came for china
a lot because it's the world's biggest
polluter and it was dialing down that
all the way through especially when it
comes to coal its plan is to still keep
adding coal power stations until 2025
and then he'd gradually reduce it and of
course president xi jinping he didn't
even go to cop uh and he didn't make a
statement it was just a written
statement uploaded to the website so
that was all fairly done but then we had
that really surprising breakthrough with
the us and china coming together to put
forward a joint statement on climate
change uh showing just how important it
is i mean these are two countries the
two biggest polluters who disagree on
almost everything around the world uh
and in china things like xinjiang and
the treatment of the minority there but
they did say they would set aside those
differences and work on climate change
together now what we didn't get from
that was any new pledges and i think
that's been clear for some time that
china is going to stick to what
president xi jinping announced last year
and work out how to achieve that it
doesn't feel like it has to bow to
international pressure but in that joint
agreement with the us uh it said that it
would try as much as possible to
accelerate its move away from coal again
it's vague uh there are no specific
targets there but at least it is down
there on paper and it perhaps gives some
impetus for china to move quicker than
it has been so far
okay thank you tom and coal mining is of
course a contentious issue even in
somewhere that likes to boast its green
credentials like
australia uh siobhan robbins standing by
in newcastle australia for his coal
mining uh region in new south wales of
course um hello to you
siobhan increasingly the the youth of
australia not at all happy with the uh
what's going on as far as coal mining is
concerned in that country but it makes a
lot of people a lot of money
yes that's right as you say i'm in
newcastle this is one of the biggest
export coal ports in the world and it's
at the mouth of the hunter valley where
there are numerous coal communities and
we've spent much of cop26 speaking to
people in those communities who make
their money from coal and they're simply
saying we're not moving away from it now
we expect our minds to be open for at
least 30 years it gives us good jobs
good prospects investment in our
community why on earth would we move
away from it but then at the same time
australia is under a lot of pressure
because they're being labeled by some as
laggards by the fact that they haven't
improved their 2030 emissions targets
they haven't signed up to this coal
pledge they haven't joined the methane
pledge and the government this week said
they wouldn't be shutting coal power of
coal-fired power stations they wouldn't
be closing coal mines they're saying
they're going to transition by investing
in new technology but when you speak to
campaigners at the conference which we
have been doing throughout the week
they've been labeling australia a
colossal fossil one of them told me this
morning the only thing that australia
has brought to cop 26 is good coffee
okay thanks very much indeed shimon
thank you let's stick with the theme of
energy now should we and should we bring
in the chief exec of scottish power
that's lindsay mcquade hi lindsay we
chatted to you at the start of cop here
we are
just using the mice at the end and a few
um delegates how's it going
um i'm taking away from it that there's
a sense that everyone now understands
what the issue is there's an acceptance
of the science i'm hearing consistent
messages whether it's from activists
general public
financiers ngos and government officials
i've spoken to from all over the world
that there's a sense that there has to
be a response there has to be an action
and i think at cop26 what we're seeing
is recognition of that we might not get
everything that we want but there's
certainly an understanding of the need
for pace and acceleration between now
and 2030 if we're going to hit those
targets in the latter part of the
century the case after paris though
i think after paris there was a sense of
of creating that baseline um i think the
series of cops in between you know
there's been some some movement some
understanding i think now
i think there's an even greater
understanding of the science the science
is now irrefutable um that's certainly
been a palpable shift in to my mind
particularly over the pandemic period
where that global consciousness has been
awoken and i think that that's resonated
with a lot of the discussions that have
been taking place here and is one and a
half still alive do you think
i think it's a life i think it's a push
i think it's a life um i think we
need to keep it alive um i appreciate
the negotiations they're still ongoing
and i'm not going to preclude anything
they're going to come up with but my ask
is that they keep moving forward they
keep it alive and that acceleration
point can't be lost in whatever is the
final agreement so that means
presumably areas like the cambo oil
fields which are off the shetlands
should not go ahead
campbell is a
hot topic i've been asked about it over
the course of the last couple of weeks
it's absolutely part of the
decision-making process that has to go
on fossil fuels are still here today
they're not part of our mix at scottish
power we're 100 green in terms of our
generation but i appreciate that there
is a need for transition and we're
seeing that with a lot of the responses
coming in from from other countries as
well there is a transition we need to be
talking about it but certainly from my
organization
we're not into fossil fuels we don't
agree nano yeah i mean there are oil
fields that are open at the moment that
are pumping oil we've got girl uh coal i
should say coming in from australia do
we really need to start opening new oil
fields
let's see it's weird about renewable
energy that's somebody else's decision
there'll be other but i'm interested in
your opinion my opinion um if i'm
speaking personally
i think that we should be just going
further and faster with the proven
renewable technologies that we know of
that would be my preference yeah and how
likely do you think it is for scottish
for scotland rather to reach its um its
renewable targets
um well i think we touched on it on
monday and we talked about 97.4 percent
of supply because of numbers coming from
renewables so scotland has a bit of a
success story in terms of its capability
but scotland's part of the wider united
kingdom where we're at 37 so there is
still a gap we still need to do more we
absolutely need to make sure that the
market mechanisms are there the
regulation is responsive so for me the
the action right now is about getting
those policies market frameworks routes
to market all of those things in place
so that i can then take investments with
confidence and deliver more green energy
scotland's doing really well and we're
going to get to 100 i have no doubt
about that and but i also need to think
about our customers more widely across
the uk okay good to talk to you again
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thank you here's a look at the
climate change as it is actually
happening right now you can see the
estimated temperature change compared to
pre-industrial levels
this is now above 1.2 degrees under that
is the estimated total carbon dioxide
emissions most of this comes from
burning fossil fuels and continues to
rise and then you can see on the right
the real-time power mix this data comes
from the national grid and illustrates
the sources of our electricity
generation at this moment in time the
renewables number there consists of wind
solar and hydroelectric power
don't forget you can listen to all the
latest climate news on climate cast
wherever you normally find your podcast
much more from cop 26 to come but for
now sally standing by for us in london
hello to sally good morning
thank you kay a very good morning to you
yes
our top story from here this morning is
a murder investigation which is underway
after two people were stabbed in
brentford in west london one man is dead
and a woman in her 80s is in a critical
condition well skies emma birchley is at
the scene
for us good morning to you emma what
more can you tell us on this
well sadly it's very common for us to be
reporting on young people having been
stabbed but what's so unusual here is
we're talking about a young man and an
elderly woman the emergency services
were called here to brentford in west
london at around 10 to 8 last night and
very sadly a young man said to be around
20 was pronounced dead at the scene and
the woman
in her 80s was taken to hospital and as
we understand it is critically ill at
that hospital now there's plenty of
police activity here as the
investigation goes on
someone is still on the run
at the moment we're told it's not being
treated as a terrorist incident but of
course everything will be on the table
now to give you an idea
of uh the location here so uh albany
parade where this happened is just off
this side road here it's a cul-de-sac
with a block of flats there uh and
there's an alleyway that runs from that
cul-de-sac onto the uh the road uh where
we are standing and plenty of the roads
around here uh have been cordoned off as
the police carry out their
investigations but they're obviously
keeping an open mind
and their priority will be to try to
find the person responsible and everyone
hoping that the the woman in her 80s is
able to pull through from what she's
been through
okay emma for now thank you
now her fans are calling it freedom day
because britney spears has been released
from her 13-year-long conservatorship
her father jamie spears no longer has
power over her life and the pop star
regains control over her own mental
personal and financial decisions for the
first time since
2008. from los angeles martha kellner
has the story
it is official the conservatorship of
britney spears has been terminated
this is the moment they found out she is
finally free
[Applause]
britney spears was 26 when her
conservatorship began she's now 39 and
for the first time in almost 14 years
back in control of her near 60 million
fortune and her life
give us your reaction to my gosh you
guys she's free we're happy this is what
we wanted
what is freedom our first act she can
have her cell phone not monitored
she can see her children at will she can
leave her house when she wants to
um basic human rights really i think
this is a great start now that she's
actually free i think uh there's a lot
more that still needs to be done to
investigating as to how this corruption
even went down
spears conservatorship started in 2008
after a mental breakdown it is an
extreme legal arrangement granted for
people who can no longer make their own
decisions in the years since the pop
star says it was abused she claims she
was drugged forced to work and even
prevented from having more children
after the verdict spears posted this
picture i can't freaking believe it she
wrote best day ever
many people here say the termination of
this conservatorship is long overdue
they also say the fight for freedom for
britney spears is still ongoing
britney's own lawyer say she will now
have to decide whether to investigate
her father and his role in this
controversy
for 13 years jamie spears controlled his
daughter's estate and personal affairs
britney says he abused his position
jamie says he only acted in her best
interest
what have you accomplished today what
does it mean for britney spears
it means that britney is free
and is this the end of the story or does
the fight continue
to get justice for britney because a lot
of people believe this is long overdue
don't they i don't think it's the end of
the story
jamie spears he might be in the line of
target you may go after jamie spears
depends on brittany
after the dust has settled she may
return to the stage but this time it
will be on her terms martha kellner sky
news los angeles
other stories making the news this
morning a former top aide to donald
trump has been charged with contempt of
congress after refusing to give evidence
about the u.s capitol riot steve bannon
was asked to testify on what he knew
about plans for the protest that ended
with the storming of congress earlier
this year the 67 year old has previously
said his communications with a former
president are protected by executive
privilege
glenda freeze a businessman who flew to
space last month with actor william
shatner has been killed in a small plane
crash the software tycoon was one of
four astronauts aboard jeff bezos blue
origin spaceship he died along with a
second man when his plane crashed in new
jersey
abba says they are over the moon after
their first studio album in almost 40
years went straight to number one the
swedish super groups record voyage sold
more than 200 000 copies in its first
week making it the fastest selling album
of the year so far
hello again everybody yep we are still
at cop26 the summit here in glasgow
how's the deal been done don't think so
ashna no i think we've got a few more
hours um to wait but it's interesting to
see that a bit of coal has been used
today to power the whole of the great
britain of the great britain of the
united kingdom
but it's interesting a lawyer said to me
yesterday that you can't talk about
climate change without talking about
fossil fuels it's a bit like talking
about the virus about the about the
pandemic without talking about the virus
so it's very much on the cards that this
is what we need to drive down to get one
point to get to 1.5 degrees we don't
limit the use of fossil fuels and
emissions just drop that simply oh that
simply won't happen and of course that
is the warming of the earth right now
we're sitting through through the groove
1.23 degrees and we just don't want it
to get above 1.5 degrees at the moment
scientists are saying it's looking like
that could get up to 2.4 and that would
just mean the destruction of so many
low-level of lying countries um islands
places like extreme things like extreme
weather would continue um so it's vital
that that stays below 1.5 if at all
possible
i'm going to go over to the tree with
you in just a second and you can i don't
know if we can have a look at it and
that's the tree what is it all about if
you were with us yesterday you'll know
if you weren't we'll tell you in just a
second but before that i want to bring
in dr virginia marshall an inaugural
indigenous postdoctoral fellow with the
australian national university
a water expert member at the world
economic forum as well hello to you
doctor that is a pretty impressive
title that you have there basically what
we want to talk about this morning are
indigenous voices and whether they're
being listened to in australia
well i think i think we can talk about
australia in the world but before i
start i i'll just say in my own language
we're a jew in in
embark uh we're
and
also thank the people of scotland
they've been absolutely warm and and
friendly to all of us
so thank you
uh i think the the most important thing
to remember is um why we're here well
i'm here also
for the university but for the
indigenous peoples organization in
australia
and one of my
missions was to also attend the local
communities and indigenous peoples
meetings
which were very important over the last
few days
and the expectation is to really
what we say in australia and in
as aboriginal torres strait islander
people's unfinished business
and that seems to be the issue every
year there's uh certain issues that are
left
undone
uh unsaid
and and not completed so this is the the
whole issue that i i saw at the
plenary for the people's plenary
yesterday
was a lot of expectations that were were
sought
to be reached however
some people do feel that they're coming
away empty-handed
australia has the highest emissions from
coal in the world though doesn't it i
mean what impact does that actually have
on the area that that you're from for
example
well it has a huge impact but you've got
to remember that it's all of the
countries of the world that make a huge
difference to our climate crisis and we
know that the the science has settled
that's quite clear
we've read the ipcc report uh throughout
universities and governments and we
quite clearly know that it's not only
australia but it's also the world if
everybody does their part and pays the
debt
uh it will be a much better trajectory
to
work towards net zero emissions and
that's what we need to accomplish
how seriously do you think the
australian government is taking climate
change
well i think that all governments need
to take climate change seriously and
that includes australia but again it
really has to be all countries in
not one country out and all other
countries in
so unless we address the extractive
industries across the world
and work together on this uh indigenous
peoples said that yesterday at the
plenary we must work together and we
must re require this network of
indigenous peoples across the world to
keep the pressure up
and that's why it's really important to
be here and and you know really coming
from a pandemic which you were talking
about earlier is is an even harder
restriction to get through and be here
so many of us
have a great commitment uh to remind our
countries of origin that they must play
their part it's immensely important
and if we were talking to ashland
earlier about potentially temperatures
rising to 2.4 degrees above 1880 levels
what would that mean for parts of
australia if that were to happen
well
it's very clear and talking with my
other colleagues from indigenous
countries elsewhere
in australia it's quite clear too we
have flooding events we have huge and
long droughts
we have uh
incredible heating events as well in
central australia and elsewhere where we
haven't experienced those temperatures
ever before
so it's very clear that people day to
day whether they're you know working in
cities or living in remote or rural
communities they're very aware and
farmers are very aware as well
that it's not normal this is not normal
and we are
going to have a very hot summer even
though we've got intense
rain at the moment
it's it's really clear the science is
clear
that
we are experiencing
different climatic conditions and and we
can also read those signs in the
environment those environmental
indicators tell us that um all the
plants the animals um the way that we
read the land uh it's really changed and
and that's concerning because indigenous
peoples in remote communities really are
going to fear the worst and and the
second um uh
issue is that people who are vulnerable
who are living on social security and
and can't pay uh those energy costs to
cool down or warm up um that's also a
concern it would be a concern across the
world including great britain okay
dr marshall we must leave it there thank
you very much indeed for joining us on
the programme this morning i was
promising you a look at what was
happening as far as the tree is
concerned ashna is standing by for us
which way are you coming here this way
there we go um tell us about the tree
this is a basically a forest of pledges
that's what it's been called written by
children across the uk this is what they
want to pledge to do to stop climate
change in their own little way there's
quite a few um young voices i guess that
can be heard through through this and
this is all about young voices in this
generation that are directly affected by
all the impacts of climate change to
choose from yes this one's a direct
message to the prime minister boris
johnson again
we'll put it back we probably will i
will
put it back but this one says dear boris
johnson we should use solar paneled wind
turbines that's a good idea so we do not
use as much electricity plus wind
turbines are very useful and if we use
solar panels for everyone it will be
great no name on that one though but a
nice picture of the wind turbine at the
top which is very nice this one here
headley just making the point do not cut
trees and they've um they've agreed that
haven't they they have they have a
deforestation deal some 19 billion
dollars that's been pledged by over 40
countries that represent some 85 of the
rain forests and forests across the
globe and that's significant because
they soak up all that carbon dioxide so
if it's not carbon capture we're looking
at other means of doing so it's always
helpful soaking up that carbon dioxide
that's warming atmosphere okay we're
looking at maybe a communique around
about eight o'clock fingers crossed
another draft okay okay looking forward
to it thanks very much of course um when
we hear about it you'll know about it
first here on scania is talking about
this talking about the planet so many of
us do want to move from one part of the
world to the next and certainly
international travel has opened up again
over the last few weeks just on monday
of this week you could fly to the united
states again for the very first time
from the united kingdom first time in
more than 600 days so what does the
future of aviation look like let's bring
in torsten langer executive vice
president of nest day corporations
renewable aviation hello to you thank
you for joining us on the programme this
morning what does the future of aviation
look like so good morning
good morning kay nice meeting you
well good question how does the future
look like i think
we need aviation so
uh future looks good um we just have to
make an effort to making it more
sustainable
and how do we do that
well there's there's various things i
mean you heard a lot on the cop 26 um um
in the recent two weeks but uh also
before the industry has been working a
lot on making aviation um more
sustainable um with technology certainly
with the with the engines uh getting
more efficient uh with having better
flight routes but
me coming from the uh from the producers
industry certainly we had introduced new
stuff that we can fly with it's called
sustainable aviation fuel and this is
one of the solutions uh for the aviation
industry in future
what's it made of
well it's made of waste and residues
currently so we're using believe it or
not to use cooking oil and animal fats
so so every time now okay you're going
to mcdonald's you just have to remember
and everything that you are producing
there or that the cooks are producing
that use cooking or we'll be using to
making fuel out of that which is quite
uh magic seems like you know but it's
carbon so it can be reused and that's
important
yep other fast food outlets are
available of course um she added um is
it more expensive
than using aviation fuel that we know of
at the moment
well it depends on what you what you're
calling expensive it does it does indeed
cost more uh we're talking currently
about three to five times but you just
wonder what is expensive uh looking into
the challenges we have in the future so
what is what is the price of carbon that
has to be taken into consideration i
mean if you just compare now fossil with
the sustainable aviation fuel or suff it
is more expensive but i think there has
to be put more into that equation and
then it's not that expensive anymore
what about electric batteries for
aeroplanes
well electric batteries everybody who
had ever had you know a little battery
in hand knows how much weight that is
and how fast that goes empty and just
imagine now you want to carry um an a380
into air
uh you would have to basically pack
these that aircraft full with batteries
uh leaving no room for passengers so
electric flying especially for long haul
and mid-hall flying is not a solution it
will certainly help
you know for the short distances in
future and there's a lot of technology
going on already on that side but for
long haul and midhole i don't see that
kicking in anytime soon
okay good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed for joining us this morning
um thanks a lot um standing by at the
board again this just so you know is the
boxing ring as we call it this is the
studio isn't it for climate tv correct
channel 525 correct absolutely streaming
till the end of the day today yeah sam
washington i've seen already this
morning she will be on air shortly i'm
sure just talk us through the board once
more yes of course so since the
industrial revolution of course the
earth has been warming to a certain
amount of degrees and this is how much
it's warmed by so it's currently sitting
at about 1.2 degrees varying around that
figure and it's going up all the time
this is a live data dashboard so it's
being tracked every single moment this
middle figure the total number of carbon
dioxide emissions currently sitting
around two million tons of it and how
we're going to get that out that's the
main question so carbon capture things
like trees that can soak it all up but
it's clearly not doing enough right now
these figures are really important these
figures are really important this is the
current amount of power that's being
produced uh to power the whole of great
britain wind at the moment 36 but
yesterday we had zero percent coal that
was powering uh the uk but look at it
now two percent and that's what people
want to avoid also nuclear and gas too
yeah and we can testify to this figure
this morning can we not
goodness me the weather's been awful
over the last couple of days still
people of glasgow have made it a very
warm welcome for us here not sure how
much lot thank you not sure how much
longer we are going to be here this has
been absolutely packed with delegates
over the last couple of weeks or so many
of them have brought their sleeping bags
we were hearing from ashna in an attempt
to try to get a deal over the line today
alok sharma who is the president of
cop26 pulling out all the stops sally
i'm not sure if he will get that deal
but um the signs are
positive is what we're going with at the
moment positive stay tuned and find out
more back to you sally in london that is
good to hear kay thank you it could be
another long day for you well in a
moment here we'll take a look at this
morning's papers with journalists thomas
copeland and pa's political
correspondent jerry scott
[Music]
did you know that reducing pollution
outside of school can help stop toxic
air getting trapped in our classrooms
[Music]
saturday will start mainly dry but some
drizzly rain is possible in the south
and east eastern england will stay dull
and damp through the morning but cloud
elsewhere will thin and break to give
some sunshine best over northern ireland
western scotland and north west england
it'll be mild once again
the afternoon will bring more of the
same but low cloud and patchy rain will
extend across northern ireland
looking at the uk's air pollution levels
are expected to remain low measuring two
or three on the daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
and with us this morning to review the
papers are journalist and broadcaster
thomas copeland and pa's political
correspondent jerry scott hello again to
you both thanks for joining us uh thomas
let's kick off uh with an article that
you've picked out in the times about
how a covid app threatens family
holidays simply because they're just not
ready yet uh to deal with children with
young passengers
yeah that's right yet more problems with
the nhs app at the moment it looks like
the app doesn't allow children under 16
to record their vaccination status or
prove that they've tested negative so if
you're going to countries italy france
elsewhere on the continent those kind of
places all require proof of vaccination
for children over the age of 12 so
that's a major problem the other thing
that the parents will have to do in that
case is pay for lateral flow tests every
couple of days they cost between 17 to
25 quid according to this article
imagine paying that every what two days
when you're on a holiday for ten days
maybe two weeks the cost really starts
to to get up there
the other problem with the app the other
end of the spectrum is that it doesn't
appear to allow older folks who are
getting their booster jobs to register
that on the app either some parts of
france are requiring booster jobs uh
increasingly and that will only that
they'll only gain more places that are
doing the same thing over the next
number of months you know the uk and
particularly the nhs has a real problem
with these kind of big tech problems
especially in health
it seems really obvious to me that that
one of the key ways in which you try to
incentivize people to get vaccinated is
to ensure that they can enjoy the
benefits that come with that fairly
easily that means having an app that
allows you to register that you've been
vaccinated that you've tested negative
that you've got your booster job so you
know we i was talking about the eye and
on the different scenarios that
whitehall have laid out into into the
next couple of years all of them are
hugely contingent upon vaccine uptake so
to encourage that
it's so obvious that the app needs to be
functioning i'm more than functioning
actually it needs to be compatible with
with people who are trying to go abroad
and elsewhere that's a really strong and
important way of trying to to encourage
people to take up the vaccine certainly
even just the cost of testing has
outpriced many families from going away
and now of course there's added
complication with the app um well on
money jerry let's talk about the front
page
of the scotsman about climate change and
the deal hanging in the balance in
glasgow and of course very much uh
finances at the center of what's being
negotiated now
yeah absolutely and you know a lot of
this is how much money these uh
countries going to be able to put
towards this this aim um yes we've gone
over by a day so far these conferences
these summits very often do
drag on um a little bit over when they
were supposed to end but alex sharma has
said that he's hopeful that the new text
that all was going to be released in
about 10 minutes time i imagine um will
get us over the line um the positives of
people like china have indicated that
they would want to sign a deal they're
frustrated
over the lack of detail on how we might
reach any aims they're included in that
um but yes i mean you heard from your
report just before we came on people are
there with their sleeping bags i know
our correspondents are and have been
prepared to be there for the whole time
so hopefully we get it all wrapped up
soon and we can crack on with making
some progress
yeah certainly it has reached uh the
critical hours crunch point uh thomas to
you now on the front page of the ft
weekend uh the netherlands reintroducing
this partial lockdown of course uh we're
also looking at austria planning uh
curbs as well on top of that bavaria in
germany has announced a state of
emergency could this be the beginning of
another wave of lockdowns in europe do
you think
well it looks likely to be i mean
the netherlands you've mentioned bavaria
and austria there as well the
netherlands imposing curfews ending
sporting uh crowds 1.5 social distancing
courtesy of 6 p.m and 8 p.m in the
evening as cases start to rise across
europe the more interesting one i think
is austria austria as of as of the last
couple days have a 9th that come monday
there will be a lockdown that applies
specifically to the unvaccinated they
will only be able to leave their houses
for essential purposes and those are the
conditions of of the the the universal
lockdown that applied earlier on in the
pandemic austria has one of the lowest
vaccine uptakes across europe only about
well more than 33 percent of people
haven't been vaccinated
the chancellor's argument is basically
one that you would hear probably quite
often which is that why should the
freedoms of two-thirds of people be
restricted because one-third of people
don't hesitate that there's still
negotiations to go on with some of the
the very powerful state governors in in
austria and the way that the federal
system works those are the people who
actually have to
actually have to facilitate and manage
this lockdown but i mean it's a really
controversial move it's not one that i
would expect to be replicated elsewhere
i there's a huge amount of backlash
already in austria about it my feeling
actually is that there's a strong
likelihood that it will never come to
pass and it might just be a fairly a
fairly high high stakes um tactic in
order to encourage people to take up the
vaccine but you know there's clear
concerns there about you know personal
liberties and freedoms and the people
who can't get vaccinated for medical or
religious reasons and can they have
their their freedoms imposed in that way
i don't think we'll see it replicated
elsewhere but we'll see what happens in
austria yeah certainly let's see um
meanwhile jerry while the world is
battling these two crises covered and of
course climate change
uh the tories once again making the
front page of the guardian amid these uh
sleaze claims in recent weeks and this
time it's the prime minister's holiday
to spain last month that's on the front
page again
yes it is its trip to marbella and the
guardians seem to have a correspondent
on the ground who has dug through some
court documents in melbourne and found
that the village stadium which we
already know is owned by the family of
the tory pierre and uh washington's
friend zach goldsmith um that that is
then the businesses that they're
involved in are then linked to this tax
evasion um
kind of problem where they've been fined
24 million euros by the spanish courts
um and it really is just the latest
after a week of sleaze allegations the
prime minister was out on the road
yesterday saying he doesn't think it's
going to hit them at the polls and some
upcoming by-elections but of course the
opinion polls are really showing that
labour have taken a lead um of course
with a couple of years out still from a
general election so i imagine it will
blow over by then um but yes it is the
kind of latest in these sleaze
allegations which i do think have harmed
the government this week um bushy sunak
seemed to suggest that he knew that and
that the government must do better um so
we'll see what what comes um next week
and in the coming weeks when they
propose a new standard system to try and
rebuild the reputation certainly the
males lead story today of that poll with
labour six points ahead certainly does
show
that those recent sleaze reports are
hurting the tory party just quickly
before we let you go thomas can we
please talk about the puffins story
huge news everyone there's been a puffin
found in yorkshire
the first time in 135 years it's been
blown 50 miles i think puffins are
famously coastal birds it's been blown
50 miles off course there's a metaphor
in there somewhere for climate change
perhaps of the pandemic but it's too
early in the morning to make it so if
you're in yorkshire it's the first time
that a puffins been found um since 1886
i don't know who recorded it at that
stage but it was found by i was found by
a vet who's caring for it and we'll turn
it in due course
to the sea where it should be and jerry
very briefly uh in the express wine
prices could soar in the new year please
what's going on
i know by up to 10 and this is a
combination of things like transport
costs and material costs of work costs
and all types of costs rising um but yes
if you thought that your uh bottle of
red might get you through the winter
you're going to be paying a little bit
more for it by the sounds of it i mean
i'm i'm heartbroken personally
very good excuse to detox though thanks
very much we'll see you guys next hour
okay that's the end of the paper review
but do stay with us because at the top
of the hour we'll be back with k burley
in glasgow
as the summit reaches those critical
hours in negotiations already over last
night's deadline it's reached crunch
point in glasgow
[Music]